[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Jennifer Jane, Eduardo
Garcia, and Phillip Baribeau,
thank you for coming to Google
today for a "Talks at" session.
Let me begin by
introducing you properly.
We have Eduardo Garcia,
subject of the film "Charged"--
documentary, rather--
Jennifer Jane, his longtime
friend, subject of the film,
as well.
And actually, they're
both co-founders
of Montana Mex food company,
a Bozeman, Montana based
specialty foods company.
We also have Phillip
Baribeau, who
is the director of "Charged,"
and previously the director
of "Unbranded,"
another critically
acclaimed documentary, which
is available on Netflix.
So, thank you for coming today.
And you know, a little
context is that I actually
met Eduardo and Phillip at an
event run by the San Francisco
49ers Foundation in
Lake Tahoe recently.
And you had a
group of people who
are used to seeing
inspirational things,
including a cadre of former and
current professional football
players, people who are not
moved easily by emotion.
And everyone I spoke to
afterwards to the person
were incredibly
inspired and moved
by what they saw with Eduardo.
And I think what's incredible
is that you've taken something
that might have
crushed other people
and actually turned it
around to make it a positive.
And you were motivated to go
out and inspire the world.
So let me begin by saying, and
asking, what actually happened
to you that day?
Give us a little bit
of background story.
You went out on a hunting
trip, if I'm not mistaken,
a backwoods trip, and your
life completely changed.
EDUARDO GARCIA: Yeah.
Hunting is part of my core, you
know, it's part of my passion,
growing up in the
hills of Montana.
So it's not uncommon that
you'll find me totally
off grid and off service from
September 1st to November 31st.
And you know, I was
hunting for elk,
and came across a dead
baby black bear, which
is about as bizarre as
you can make it, you know?
And not knowing that that
dead bear was on 2400 volts,
I took a knife out and
put it in my left hand
to just investigate,
and received
a shock that ended up resulting
in, you know, 48 days of ICU
and nearly taking my life.
SPEAKER: So Eduardo,
one thing that
really makes me
stop and think here
is that you're a person, both
now and before the injury,
before the incident, someone
who really depends on your body,
right?
As a chef, as an outdoorsman.
And so you went from
zero to 60, being
able to depend on a
fully capable body,
right, to not being able to
do that in a split second.
So what did that teach
you about yourself?
And I think, more
importantly, if you
were to be able to go
back in time, right,
would you choose to have
let that happen now, or not?
EDUARDO GARCIA: If I
could go back in time,
I think there's other things I
would change, quite honestly.
You know, it's quite
interesting, you know.
I think we rely on the
things that come natural
and our primary skill sets.
Whether they're physical or
psychological or emotional,
you know, we go to those
things that we know best.
And so when you lose
your latissimus dorsi
and they just basically
remove it from your hip
and wrap it around your torso
to make up for the obliques
and pectoral
muscles that I lost,
you no longer have that
latissimus anymore.
But I have to tell you
that, once that's removed,
you find out quite
quickly that you have
all these submuscle groups.
And it's just a metaphor
for life, right?
You have all these
subgroups of smaller muscles
that are just waiting
for their day in the sun.
They're just waiting to get out
and kick some ass, you know.
So when you call on them and
you say, OK, little guys, it's
time to step up and,
like, flex, they do.
And so for that, my life
is much richer, you know?
You take that down to
the other parts of life,
and through this injury there's
a huge, huge stroke of humility
I've been dealt, and
then a phenomenal fount
of understanding about
myself, my friends, my family,
and maybe even my
purpose, you know?
SPEAKER: You know, one of the
things that I think about when
I think about your journey
is that, as strong as you
are, it's not about you, right?
It's about the community
that surrounds you.
And I'm looking at some of
them in this room, people
who have dedicated a large
portion of their lives
to helping tell
your story, right?
None of us are an island.
So what did you learn about
the importance of friendship
and people going
through this process?
EDUARDO GARCIA: Yeah.
It's interesting, the
mind of a patient,
right, everybody is
giving you everything.
Well, hopefully.
You've got everyone from
your surgeons to your nurses,
and then to your
friends and community,
like you mentioned, Phil.
But it's all coming this way.
And at some point, I think
there's a Eureka moment that
hits where you realize, like--
you kind of, like, look at
Jen, and you're like, so--
remember, there's a
scene in the film,
for anyone that hasn't
seen it, where Jen's
been sleeping for 48 days
in this recliner that's
spring-loaded.
So you lean back, it kind of
pops into a reclining position,
but if you take any pressure
off it, [THUNK], right?
So in her sleep,
she would doze off,
and then it would just
launch her forward.
JENNIFER JANE: It
wasn't heavy enough.
EDUARDO GARCIA: It
And Jen filmed a lot,
all of the ICU stay.
And so there's a scene where
Jen put her camera on a tripod
and filmed this jerry-rigging
MacGyver moment where she's
taking her carry-on
bag and using her belt
and rigging it to the
back of the recliner
so that it lays flat.
And she caught beautifully
just raw footage of me saying,
geez, you've been
doing that every day?
So at some point, the patient
switches and you realize, like,
what it takes to be a caregiver,
what it takes to be a friend,
you know?
And that's oftentimes
even harder, really,
than the patient, because the
patient's getting everything.
SPEAKER: Which is actually a
good segue in that, you know,
Jennifer, correct
me if I'm wrong,
but you had been partners
with Eduardo previous
to the accident, had
actually gone back
to England to
continue your life,
and came back to
actually take care of him
and help him through
this journey.
JENNIFER JANE: Yes.
SPEAKER: And to
capture it on film.
JENNIFER JANE: Mhm.
SPEAKER: So, why
did you do that?
What motivated you?
JENNIFER JANE:
Well, there's a lot
of answers to that
question, I guess, but the--
so for anybody that
hasn't seen the film,
Eduardo and I had a very
turbulent relationship.
And about-- I think it was
about 10 days before he
was injured I was like, you
know what, I'm gonna go.
And I did.
And I flew back to England.
And so I was actually
in England when
I got the phone call
that he had been injured.
And I got on the plane--
actually, just before I got
on the plane, I spoke to him,
and we thought it could be
the last conversation, which
was obviously very emotional.
And then I got on
this plane, and he
went into his first
surgery, and I had
zero way to contact the ground.
So I had eight hours
just sat on this plane
hoping that he would be OK.
And during that time
was when I got to think.
You know, in a way it was good
to have that time to really
think about who he is to me.
You know, I still
love him very much,
even though we weren't
together and we
had had this type
of relationship,
and wondering if
he would survive,
and thinking about filming.
And that was where that kind
of whole moment happened.
And we landed, and luckily
he was still alive.
And you know, it was
an awesome moment.
And then I got to the hospital,
and then it was really
that he continue to survive.
And that was-- you know,
I just stayed there
throughout the whole
thing, because really,
at the very beginning,
when I first went,
I had no idea what
was going to happen.
And then once you're
there, obviously,
when you love someone, you
don't want to leave their side.
And I just stayed.
And together, we got through it.
SPEAKER: But why film it?
Like, what was that
crystallized moment
you decided this is something
that I want to capture?
And did you want to capture it
for yourself, for each other,
or for the world?
JENNIFER JANE: Sure.
There was a couple of reasons.
So we'd just been filming,
Phil, Eduardo, and I,
for a television show
that Eduardo and I
had been working on.
So I had a camera.
I was used to filming Eduardo.
So that was one side of things.
Another side of it
was I was listed
as one of the signers for him.
So when he was in operation,
I could sign things away.
And I was worried that
he was on so many drugs
that afterwards he
wouldn't remember what he'd
been through, and maybe
on the other side of it
be why-- you know, why did that
happen, why did this happen.
And it would be good to have
footage and photography to say,
hey, this is what
your hand looked
like before it had to be
removed, and things like that.
So it was a little bit of
personal documentation,
a little bit because we
were used to filming.
And as it transpired
while we were in the ICU,
we learned that so many people
don't get out the other side
because they're so
unmotivated for rehabilitation
and learning from the doctors
and nurses during that time
that showing other people
how to get through it
would be beneficial.
So we just continued and
turned it into a documentary.
EDUARDO GARCIA: And
I should add, too,
we had a lot of support.
JENNIFER JANE: Huge.
EDUARDO GARCIA: We were working
with a production team called
Citizen Pictures
out of Denver who
were quick to arrive
and lend some gear.
And we were in touch with
Phil, who, as Jen mentioned,
you know, had just filmed
a trailer for a TV concept
we have.
And Phil was also incredibly
supportive in just
the very early days
of, yeah, document it.
I mean, that's the
power of storytelling,
you know, is don't
know-- sometimes,
you don't know what you're
going to do with it,
but you just go out and
you just start capturing.
SPEAKER: Doesn't
always work out.
I'm sure that most documentaries
that start don't get finished.
JENNIFER JANE: Right.
And--
SPEAKER: So Phillip,
is that true, right?
And I guess the second thing is,
you're a critically acclaimed
documentary filmmaker.
You just released "Unbranded."
You're doing other things.
What kind of drew
you to this project?
How did you get involved?
How did it come together?
PHILLIP BARIBEAU: Sure.
Yeah, like they mentioned,
it started with this trailer
for a TV show.
So Ed, Jen and myself, we
all live in Bozeman, Montana.
And they approached me with
this idea of outdoor cooking
and making these meals in the
outdoor while being active
and surfing and
skateboarding and climbing,
all these cool things.
So we spent six months
to a year working
on that, put together
this awesome trailer,
Citizen Pictures went
out and pitched it.
Almost sold within five
days of the Food Network,
and he got his injury.
So put a complete halt on that.
And that's where
Jen was explaining
she decided to film the
entire stay in the ICU
with this incredible footage.
Really raw, emotional--
just footage
that you don't really see in
survival stories or films,
or anything like that.
And then when Ed
got back to Montana,
we just kept filming
all these stages.
So him getting back into
the outdoors, into life.
And we got to a point where
we kind of all sat together--
Dennis Aig, producer
that's also here--
and decided what do we
do with this archive.
Like, once he started
recovering physically,
we started to see
the both of them
having these effects on people,
on kids, in a positive way.
So let's use this story on a
bigger level and make a film.
SPEAKER: You know,
listening to all this,
one thing I walk away
with is the importance
of, again, people--
I want to go back to
that-- and advocacy.
And I'm delighted to let
everyone know today we actually
have Erin Hattersley with us.
Erin is the interim lead
with the Googler Disability
Alliance, which is at GoDA.
And for those of you who aren't
familiar with the disability
alliance, it
advocates on behalf of
and helps thousands of
Googlers around the world who
have disabilities that are
either known or unknown.
So it's one of
the most important
what we call ERGs, Employer
Resource Groups, here.
And when I have gotten
to know some people who
are part of the
Disability Alliance,
quite often they
have an advocate,
whether it's someone at
home, right, or someone here
at Google, their manager, a peer
who really makes their lives
better, and kind of makes their
professional life at Google
possible.
So I have a two-part
question, really.
Eduardo, people find themselves
in a situation like yours,
right, or a medical
situation, how important
it is to have an
advocate, both in terms
of getting your
life back on track
and I would also
posit actually helping
navigate the medical
industrial complex,
where you have doctors
all over the place?
So can you give us
some advice there?
Because everyone, at
some point or another,
finds himself in a situation
not exactly like yours,
but in a situation like that.
What would you recommend?
EDUARDO GARCIA: Yeah,
that's a really good point,
and a great question.
And actually, for
me, to that point,
that was the genesis
of my turning point
to say, yeah, I'm
gonna go all in
and sort of reveal this
very private, exceptionally
intimate part of
my life, and that I
think this can be a tool and a
resource for a lot of people.
And you know, when Jen and
I, when we were in ICU,
we spent quite a bit
of time googling.
JENNIFER JANE: Yeah.
A lot of time googling.
EDUARDO GARCIA: We did.
It was a best friend, truly.
Just put yourself
in this position,
and this is the power of
sharing information, which
is I think what we're doing
with "Charged," you know,
is we're sharing
information also.
So we're kind of
in cahoots, right?
We're in business together,
in that I just lost my hand.
You wake up and you're
completely rewriting who
you are, what do you do?
I mean, I think you start
researching very quickly.
How do you surf with one hand?
How do you fly fish?
How do you cook?
How do you do all these things?
What does the term
prosthetic mean?
You know, who is
the best upper body,
you know, prosthetician
in the United States.
And you start looking into it.
And you're in a scrambled
frenzy to understand
where you're going to find your
way back to being, like, whole
again.
And so really, with
this film, you know,
I think you need to
have an advocate.
You need to have-- and we found
mentors in Salt Lake City,
because I was at the University
of Utah, other amputees that
were really doing what we're
trying to do with "Charged."
They survived insane injury, or
were congenital-based amputees.
And then I could
look at their story.
You know, there's a chef,
Michael Caines, in the UK.
And I remember watching a
YouTube video of him cooking.
And you know, all
respect to that chef.
I remember watching and it
was, like, one of the first--
it was, like, one
of maybe two times
where I truly erupted in
just total grief and loss,
because I'm watching a chef
cook with a prosthetic, which
is phenomenal to think of.
But at the same time, I'm
watching a dance and a movement
I used to know by
heart, and I'm seeing
it done in a way
that just seemed
like you had muck
boots on your hands,
and you're trying to do
this dexterous movement.
I'm thinking like, oh, I gotta--
you know, that-- it crushed me.
But at the same time,
it's impressive.
So it gave us--
I mean, having
other examples was
that light at the end
of the tunnel to say,
OK, you're an amputee,
but it's not game over.
You know, look at
this guy fishing,
look at this person
wakeboarding.
There's folks all over
the world painting,
doing amazing things
without their limbs.
You know, I think if
the brain and the spirit
and soul and the heart are
intact, like that's square one.
SPEAKER: So it kind of
makes me think-- and this
is sort of a question
for all three of you,
because sometimes it's hard
to see yourself, right?
You have your own experience,
and then your experience
is shared by others
who are watching
you go through the journey.
So what about you was the
physically hardest thing
to do when this was done?
What were two or
three things that
just were rote memory
beforehand and afterwards
were incredibly hard?
And what did that teach you?
And having watched
Eduardo through this,
like, what did you see?
And also, how do people
react to you differently,
right, before and after?
And I'm sure you'd have
thoughts on that, as well.
JENNIFER JANE: I remember
opening jars became a team
effort, you know?
Like I'd hold the jar, and
Ed would unscrew the jar.
That was one of the
first little things
that I think I noticed in
terms of physical change.
PHILLIP BARIBEAU: I mean, the
biggest thing-- he says it
in that scene that you saw with
the Challenged Athletes-- is Ed
and I, we hunt together, we
hike together, all these things.
He tackles the physical.
He puts his head down and
he gets it done, learns--
the first day fly
fishing, he had it down
and he was catching fish.
It's incredible.
But it was the emotional journey
that was the most difficult. So
going through that
with him, and I
knew we had to document that
process of, once he got back
to all the things--
cooking and the stuff
in the outdoors--
I saw his biggest
challenge was when
he tackled everything
that happened to him,
recovering things
in his relationship
and his family and
everything like that.
So by far I saw that as
the biggest challenge.
SPEAKER: And speaking
of which, you know,
Montana I would kind
of view as a character
in this documentary,
right, in that it's
an entity unto itself.
So what role did
Montana in general,
and nature in particular,
have on your therapy
and your recovery?
EDUARDO GARCIA: I could get
lost down a serious tunnel here.
And I tend to be wordy
if I'm given a leash,
or not given a leash.
SPEAKER: I'll cut
you off, don't worry.
EDUARDO GARCIA: OK.
SPEAKER: Great.
EDUARDO GARCIA: No,
I'll keep it succinct,
because it is quite simple
that Montana, for me,
is just a super,
super true example
of just, like,
simple perfection.
It's nature abounds.
You have landscapes and sort of
viewscapes everywhere you turn.
And when you are at square
one starting over and trying
to re-imagine, you know,
what better place than
to-- and maybe communicate
with nature on some level,
and to sort of just open
yourself up to dream big
and say, OK, I'm gonna see
how far I can walk today, or--
you know, it was just an
awesomely inspiring setting
to start rewriting my story.
And then there were some
more subtle parts, too.
And for me, you know, I spend
a lot of time, if I can,
in the woods hiking or on the
river fishing, or generally
just outside.
And if you look at what we do
here, what we do with our mind
and what we do with our hands,
we're striving consistently,
I think, for some
type of perfection
or some type of
repeatable perfection.
And mother nature,
I don't think--
perfection is very
different in mother nature.
It's consistently
different from one leaf
to the next on the same branch.
And in that, I think I started
to see an example of, OK, I
mean, that tree is
beautiful, even though it's
got a limb snapped off it.
And it's different.
SPEAKER: Sure.
EDUARDO GARCIA: You know?
And I started to see
sort of like, hey,
well, I'm nature-made,
and I'm different.
But it doesn't mean that this
can't be beautiful still,
you know, how I view myself.
SPEAKER: So, you know,
Eduardo, one thing
that kind of blew me away
was the fact that you were
in the hospital, you were
recovering from this,
and you found out at
that same point in time
that you were suffering
from testicular cancer.
So, you know, at what point
in your recovery journey
were you there, and how did
that affect you going forward?
EDUARDO GARCIA: It's
fairly inconvenient.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, if you would call it,
it was one of those things where
you--
and I say we, actually,
because it was a team.
When you have 21 surgeries
ahead of you, or in totality,
to accomplish, you need to
stop halfway through those
and go tackle three months
of chemo, it's strange.
You know, I honestly
feel like I didn't
have much of an opportunity
to be even scared by it,
because I was in
something that I
felt had far more
grave consequences.
And it took years for me
to come around and actually
own up to the fact that
I'm a cancer patient,
I'm a cancer survivor.
You know?
But I really just kind of took
it on, did the chemotherapy,
shelved it.
Jen reminds me often.
She's like, hey, don't always
just put on a brave face,
it was horrible.
You know, like you were
ill and sick and in pain
and felt awful a
lot of the times.
And I think there's
a part of my brain
that tends to try and
forget about that,
and that it was just
this three-month chapter
that I shelved
and then went back
to kind of reconstructing
my scalp wounds
and some of my other injuries.
So really, I think
where I own it today
is in trying to work with cancer
support and cancer awareness
groups.
Like First Descents does
a phenomenal job taking--
I think their program
is open for 20-year-olds
through 40-year-olds, to put
them in a community to say,
hey, it's OK to own
cancer in whatever level
you're at, whether
you're in treatment
or you're surviving
or, you know,
if you're in a
terminal situation,
and still access your
limitations, like go big.
Surf, climb, kayak,
all their programs.
So for me, it was a
hiccup that has further
just engaged my recovery.
SPEAKER: So Jen,
you know, anyone
who's been through a
situation like this
knows that the caregiver,
they're giving care,
but their life is continuing.
JENNIFER JANE: Mhm.
SPEAKER: Life beckons.
You have to make money,
get a job, get stuff done.
So what were your
greatest challenges
in taking care of Eduardo
during this period
and actually running
your own life,
and getting your own
life back on track?
JENNIFER JANE: Sure.
I think we were actually
very fortunate in the sense
that we co-own the same company.
So while we were
in the hospital,
we'd still be working
on the company.
You know, I had the
laptop out in my chair
next to his bed just, you know,
running as much as I could do.
So in the sense of me
working and earning money,
we were fortunate
in that situation.
But I think one of
the toughest things
is remembering to
look after yourself,
and then finding joy
in the small things.
Like, we definitely tried
to watch stand-up comedy
and dance and do all these
little things that we
could to keep ourselves lifted.
And then I think yeah,
it really is just
accepting what you've
lost as you've lost,
so we were very much,
OK, the hand is gone.
There's nothing we
can do about that.
However, there's many other
things that we've still got.
Let's not lose our
house, let's not lose
our business, let's focus
on everything we still had.
And I think that helped both
of us get through everything.
SPEAKER: Team effort.
JENNIFER JANE: Yeah.
SPEAKER: So Phil, as
you kind of like--
as a documentary filmmaker,
and you know, here
in the audience we have people
who tell stories for a living--
some communications
folks, marketing people,
as well-- so you have a
multi-layered story here
with a lot of emotion, a lot of
different concurrent and hard
events, right?
So how did you bring together
a cohesive narrative,
a story that actually
resonated with people?
PHILLIP BARIBEAU: Sure.
SPEAKER: So what's
the story there?
How do you do it in
an hour and a half?
PHILLIP BARIBEAU: Yeah.
I wish our editor Tony Hale
was here to help explain that,
because he had to go through
hundreds of hours of footage
to pull this together.
But you know, when
we sat down when
we had all this
footage to decide what
are we doing with this, is
this just a half-hour survival
show, what's the bigger picture,
and as we started diving
into it, learning more about
the relationship, his past,
his family, different things
with his father, we're like,
there's a bigger story here.
And really, we needed their
trust to be able to dive
into that, to expose
some mistakes that
were made in the past
to show where he's come,
where the both of
them have come, today.
So that was our greatest
challenge was getting there.
And I remember we had a talk
about I didn't want to do this
if it was going to
ruin our friendship,
because later on
they can watch it
and say, like, oh, you made
me look terrible there.
SPEAKER: Right.
PHILLIP BARIBEAU: Like,
you know, I've seen it.
It's tough.
But really, that's not our goal.
Our goal is to show all
this, to be vulnerable,
to show what they came through
to get to the other side.
So it was amazing that they
trusted our team to dive that
deep into the whole journey.
SPEAKER: And so I'm thinking
about your relationship, right.
So Eduardo, Jen, what
was your relationship
like before this
happened, and what
is your friendship like now?
And how has that changed?
How has what happened
to both of you, really,
how has it impacted your
friendship and relationship,
way of working together as
co-business owners today?
It must be complicated.
JENNIFER JANE: Mhm, it's--
EDUARDO GARCIA:
To say the least.
JENNIFER JANE: Yeah.
I think when you go
through something like this
with someone, it
definitely forces
you to shift the less
important stuff to the side.
I think maybe if Eduardo
hadn't been injured,
we would have probably gone
our separate ways maybe more
quickly.
But you develop--
I think they call it a trauma
bond, is what they call it,
is when you're really with
somebody the whole time.
And I think our friendship
blossomed through that,
because our relationship
before was extremely
intense and turbulent.
And I think the
injury was just like,
OK, I definitely care
about this person,
and I definitely want him
to be OK, and to be there.
What do you think?
EDUARDO GARCIA: Yeah,
no, I agree with that.
I think, you know,
life or death seems
to be the great
equalizer, right?
And not saying that all mistakes
are forgiven should you survive
something, but it just
levels the playing field,
only just a little bit,
to-- for me, you know?
And individually, whether you're
the patient or the caregiver,
to say, OK, well tomorrow, you
know, who will I decide to be?
You know, how am I
going to rewrite this?
Whether it's my own
journey or my journey
as a friend with Jen, or
others for that matter.
And you know, I think it's--
when someone has impacted
your life as Jen has,
you know, being there in such
a crucial part of my life,
it's a really terrific
feeling, to be honest,
to wake up and kind of know
how high the stakes are.
I mean, sometimes it's nice
when the stakes are high,
because you feel more
driven to purpose.
SPEAKER: You know, when
I think about this,
I guess a question I have is
is optimism a choice, right?
And is it a choice you have to
make each day and each minute?
Because looking at what you've
gone through, what all of you
have gone through, I think there
must have been moments when you
were ready to kind of throw in
the towel, just say screw it,
I don't want to do it.
I don't want to do
the film, I don't
want to recover anymore, I just
want to go home and watch TV.
Right?
So like, what
would you recommend
to anyone who's gone through
any type of a trauma,
a physical trauma, psychological
trauma, relationship
trauma, in terms of getting
their life back on track?
And you know, is it a decision?
How do you do it?
And how do you go about it?
EDUARDO GARCIA: Is that for me?
SPEAKER: All of you.
JENNIFER JANE: Yeah.
I was going to
say, I think what's
interesting is obviously
what we went through was,
without a doubt, a huge thing.
But the reality is that,
in a burn trauma ICU,
life is very tough.
You're surrounded by people that
are dealing with insane things.
And so I think that's when
you really kind of take it in
yourself and say, OK, you
know, this is our little room,
this is our moment, what
do we have [INAUDIBLE] OK,
he's fortune.
In his case, he's
only lost one hand.
He still has a hand.
We met a lot of people who'd
lost both arms and both legs.
We were meeting people who
had been burned to their core
and, you know, they
were going to be
in a bed for the next
five years, at least,
if they make it through.
Like, you definitely have to
take into yourself what are we
dealing with.
And we tried to find the
positives as much as we could.
And I think, by doing that,
we did actually do very well.
And it's incredible
what people go through,
and what they deal with.
SPEAKER: You must have met
some pretty amazing people
through this process.
JENNIFER JANE: Amazing people.
SPEAKER: Do you keep
in touch with them?
JENNIFER JANE: Yes.
SPEAKER: You do?
EDUARDO GARCIA: Oh, yeah.
SPEAKER: Yeah?
JENNIFER JANE: Yeah.
EDUARDO GARCIA: Yeah.
Yeah, that's--
Phil, you should--
you want to say
something towards--
PHILLIP BARIBEAU:
Well, I would say, one,
it didn't, unfortunately,
make the film,
but a big reason we decided--
you decided-- to tell your story
was we went back to the ICU
in Salt Lake City and met
up with doctors and nurses.
And basically, in
the trailer where
you see Eduardo said to
me, I would never go back.
And that's something he's
only heard a couple times,
and through all of his patients.
So it's like going back seeing
the effect, and on both ways.
He's inspired to
talk to his doctors,
but they're also inspired
to see him come back,
and where they've come to.
So.
EDUARDO GARCIA: That's Dr.
William Morris in the film,
who was the surgeon on
call when I walked in,
quote unquote, in his words, a
bag of bones with a heartbeat.
And in that day, you know,
he whispered in my ear,
it's so good to see
you again, following
kind of a powwow in
the hallway with nurses
that were on our team
and on our care team.
And I swear, I felt so much
emotional pain come out
in those words, for
everyone he's never saved,
for every patient that he was
not able to keep on earth.
And I also felt
like he was saying--
because a lot of them give up.
A lot of people give up
when the going gets tough.
You know, the question from
Phil was about optimism,
and whether that's
a choice or not.
And that is a
choice, but it's also
a choice on whether we
share that or not, right?
You know, we can keep so many
of these beautiful things
that we have ownership right
here, and never let them out,
you know?
Something happens on the street
on our way out of this building
today, and someone
bumps into you,
we have a choice on whether
we turn around and scowl
or whether we just give a human
benefit of the doubt of just
that was someone's shoulder on
my shoulder, good to be alive,
you know?
And rather than bounce
that negativity out.
And so I think when
Dr. William Morris,
in that moment with him,
I felt like, what am I
doing hiding this recovery?
It's true, you know, I survived
something I should probably--
I should not have lived through.
And maybe there's
a responsibility
in sharing that with others.
And in turn, maybe through
this film, through "Charged"
and through this
documentary, there's
some story that supersedes
my story, you know,
and kind of affects
others that then others
can, in turn, take and
pass on and pass on,
which is-- you know, it's
first you've got to dream big,
and then with that dream you've
got to act on those dreams,
and be optimistic
about our own ability
to overcome almost all
obstacles, to a point.
SPEAKER: So this is a
question for all three of you.
Like, you know, in doing this
and going out and telling that
story, you've built a community
of, you know, injured veterans,
I would presume, right,
like children who have lost
their arms-- we saw the video--
people who have been
through really, really hard
stuff, really,
really hard times.
So if you look
through all of them,
if you had to kind
of draw a narrative,
like a couple common
points between all of them
in terms of what they've
done to rebuild their lives,
what are those two
or three things
that you've seen with people
who've actually done that thing
and actually are successful in
recovering, or on that journey?
EDUARDO GARCIA: Unending
belief, ownership--
you know, be true to yourself--
SPEAKER: What does
that mean, ownership?
I've got to ask.
EDUARDO GARCIA: It means
knowing or pretending
that I have my left hand, right?
It means being very proud of who
I am every day when I wake up,
and just this is me.
This is me out of
the closet, you know?
And then relying
on others, right.
Responsibly relying on others.
Being like, hey
Phil, I'm challenged
by you wanting to film me
tomorrow, but let's talk about
it, you know, rather than
just letting things happen.
Share the process
with your team.
That's how the team
develops, you know?
JENNIFER JANE: Oh, absolutely.
I think perseverance
is the one thing.
You know, if I said to you,
go and learn the violin
and you practiced
it three times,
then you wouldn't be very good.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
JENNIFER JANE: [INAUDIBLE]
learn the violin
and you practiced every single
day for hours, by this time
next year, you might not
be too bad, you know?
And it's the same
thing, I think,
from meeting these
people are getting
used to using prosthetics
and those things.
It's literally trying
not to get angry
and just accepting and just
doing those little tiny things
every single day, and
then building on that.
And a year later,
it's manageable.
PHILLIP BARIBEAU: The thing I
noticed, just the simple thing,
is just the
appreciation for life.
Like with that Challenged
Athletes group and we
filmed this triathlon.
All of them had that same thing,
and treated every single day
as a gift.
And so that was
really neat to see.
SPEAKER: So what can--
tell us about the
documentary itself,
meaning that, you know,
what are your plans with it?
How can people in the audience,
how can people watching this
on YouTube, what can
they do to actually help
get that story out,
and where do you
want to bring the
story from here?
Where can people see it?
EDUARDO GARCIA: Sure.
So the "Charged" film is in the
middle of its festival process
right now.
So we are touring the country
showing in select theaters
in festivals around the nation.
If you go to our
website, chargedfilm.com,
or follow us on Facebook--
and we update it constantly,
our festival schedule.
We are looking and
hoping for distribution,
so that anybody in the world can
get online and watch the film.
And so fingers crossed
that's upcoming.
And then, you know,
for me personally,
I hope to use it as
a tool to continue
to keep me present with
this process, you know?
And I think it is my
calling to say something
like that, that is to
use this as an example,
to remind me every day and to
just share with others what
surviving can really look like.
You can thrive.
AUDIENCE: I had
the immense honor
of seeing this film at Telluride
Film Festival last year.
And it was met with immense--
I mean, people just
were blown away.
One of my favorite
scenes from the film
was when a young boy at a high
school you were speaking at
comes up and kind
of very vulnerably
comes and talks to you about
his brother who went through--
I think he was a burn
victim or something.
I'm curious what that's like
for you, being on the receiving
end of people seeing you so
vulnerable on the screen,
and then coming up and
sharing their own stories.
EDUARDO GARCIA: Yeah.
I feel like it's a tithe, right?
And it's interesting
when there's
sort of a reciprocal figure
eight that happens between you
and me in that exchange, in
that I need to continually feel
purpose with this project.
And it's not even a project.
It's part of my life,
is sharing this film.
And just, like, feeling
that emotional release
from my surgeon in the
hallway basically charging me
and saying, what are
you doing with this?
Why aren't you using this
for good in the world?
And then if-- if we
can share this film
and somehow access a
part of someone that
is not Eduardo Garcia,
but is somewhere
inside of that other person
where then they open up
and they own an experience
that is like a splinter,
and they allow it to come
out, they become empowered
with their own voice and
with their own emotions
and their own strengths
to be vulnerable, right?
And then-- so when I
get that, it just, it
puts a big, big smile on my face
and in my heart just to say,
yeah, this is working.
This is what needs
to happen, you know,
sharing this joie de vivre, you
know, like this joy of life,
in any form.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that you wouldn't change
what happened to you, but
that you would have done--
if you could go
back, you would have
done some other
things differently,
or you would change
some other things.
So I was just kind of curious
what you meant by that.
EDUARDO GARCIA: I think the--
that's a question I get
asked a lot is, hey,
if you could go
back to that day,
would you do it differently?
And I mean, I would--
that day, I was just being me.
I was hunting.
It was an accident,
and an injury
that no one ever
wishes on anyone.
And it's really-- it's just
unfortunate for me that
the other decisions I've made
in my life that have affected
others--
lying, cheating,
stealing-- you know,
those I'm not proud of, right?
Those are moments of weakness
where I really stepped outside
of that true person that I
would like to be in this world,
and for whatever reason
digressed into a person
that, you know, I
don't particularly
want to lead with every day.
So I think that's
what I mean by it,
is I want to wake up and
be an honest man every day.
And the day I was out
in the woods hiking,
it was a very honest situation.
And therefore, I hold no
angst towards that day.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious,
as both a company,
as Google, and then
as individuals,
how we can be most
helpful in propelling
your story or your
mission or whatever.
If you were to have an ask
of us, what is that ask?
SPEAKER: That's
a great question.
Thank you.
You have 70,000 Googlers
who can help, so, please.
JENNIFER JANE: Yeah, I think--
oh, you want to answer that?
EDUARDO GARCIA: Yeah, great
question, how can others help.
This is an independent film.
You know, this is
something that we
did because, as-- collectively,
as a filmmaker, as participants
and subjects, we said this
is a message worth sharing.
And yet our bandwidth is
like a cocktail straw, right?
And we are not distributed yet.
So the help that we need
is to go watch our trailer,
read our bios, and
understand kind of more
about film and our message.
And then share it.
Share it, and share it, and
share it again, because I do
believe that there is a value
to sharing this joy of life
with others.
And "Charged" film for me
is very much just that.
It's an example of what
really living charged can be.
And I think it's probably
a really terrific time
in our world to get that
message out in a big way.
SPEAKER: Here, here.
Well, Phillip,
Eduardo, and Jennifer,
thank you for coming
to Google today.
And rest assured, we are going
to do all we can to help you.
JENNIFER JANE: Thank you.
EDUARDO GARCIA:
Thank you for all.
[APPLAUSE]